hey 42 here accents are strange things a
language can be spoken using the exact
same words but in hundreds of different
ways sometimes accents are so dissimilar
that to speakers of the same language
with different accents can't even
understand one another we've had accents
for thousands of years the Bible speaks
of a tribe that identified their enemies
by the facts that they couldn't
correctly pronounce the word Shibboleth
so they basically killed everyone with a
funny accent nice but it's not just
humans that have accents animals also
tweet bar and move differently depending
on where they come from the UK is well
known for its large and varied array of
regional accents a study in the UK found
that cows in England Moo differently in
different parts of the country their
Moo's seem to somewhat reflect the
accent of their owner but what actually
causes accents humans have a remarkable
talent for being able to quickly detect
an accent we're actually really really
good at it humans can detect if someone
has a different accent from themselves
after just 30 milliseconds of speech we
can even do the same thing if we listen
to that 30 milliseconds of speech play
backwards on a recording well done brain
you're a lot smarter than you look so
where does this superhuman
accent divining power come from it all
starts from when we're only an
itty-bitty little baby humans aren't
just inherently good at learning
language it's a lot simpler than that
during that first few years were hyper
receptive to noises around us we quickly
learn to imitate those noises babies
subconsciously listen in to people's
conversations around them and so that's
what the child learns to imitate those
peoples languages and speech patterns
just because a baby is born to Spanish
parents in Spain it doesn't necessarily
mean that Spanish is destined to be its
native tongue if that newborn Spanish
baby is placed in say England from birth
adopted by English
parents it will grow up speaking fluent
English not only that it will have an
English accent
not Spanish in fact this noise imitation
goes even further than we initially
fought during a study bird noises were
played to an infant child soon
afterwards the child was able to
accurately imitate those bird noises but
children quickly lose this ability to
effortlessly reproduce noises as they
grow up that's why it's significantly
harder for an adult to learn a new
language than a child but that doesn't
mean you can't change your accent it's
significantly harder to do as you grow
up but when an adult moves to a new area
they do slowly lose their accents in
favour of a new one although this can
take several years a famous example of
this is when Britain colonized America
over several years to settle has lost
their traditional Queen's English accent
in favour of well the American accent
specifically southern groan the English
gave America words touches your butts
and that's more of a dialect issue than
an accent it's believed that accents are
formed because of variations in the
physical makeup of different ethnicities
different ethnic groups are born with
different shaped noses mouths and
throats these subtle differences alter
the way that words are formed for
example a group of people with slightly
wider than average throats bigger noses
and larger chests will speak in a deeper
pitch on the other hand people with a
narrower throat
smaller noses and smaller chest will
speak with a more nasally and higher
pitched accent this can be seen with
individuals of East Asian origin due to
their smaller than average body frames
they tend to sound higher pitched when
speaking English than Caucasians but
that's not the only reason that we have
accents physical variations such as this
only have subtle effects on our accent
the factors most responsible for
different accents are influences from
different languages and different
cultures specifically the mixing of
those different languages and cultures
humans like to explore and is because of
our explorative nature
that different regions have different
accents for example when the Germanic
people came to Britain in the fifth
century they brought their language and
culture with them over time this changed
a way that people in England spoke
creating new accents because people from
all kinds of different regions and
cultures came to Britain today Britain
has an estimated 56 different major
accents across the country that's a hell
of a lot for the relatively small
islands that it is for that you can
thank the huge wealth of other countries
the UK is parked next to the location
where the overseas settlers first came
ashore and made their home determined
what accents that region of Britain
would ultimately have Britain is a great
example of this but this exact same
reasoning holds true for any country
that has different accents which is most
countries you may be wondering what's
the difference between an accent and a
dialect an accent is the way one sounds
when speaking it's the unique way in
which people pronounce words and the
musicality if you like of their voice a
dialect however refers to the linguistic
system as a whole particularly the
grammatical features of the way a person
talks to put all that more simply a
dialect is what people say and an accent
is a way that they say it as for me well
I have a West Lancashire accent which is
why my accent doesn't sound like the
traditional plummy boarding school type
accents which people from all around the
world usually associate with England not
accent by the way which some people
simply refer to as Queen's English is
actually called received pronunciation
America has a similar so called generic
accent las' accent called general
american it's a mix of Midwest and West
Coast accents received pronunciation and
general American are often regarded as
the standard accents less accents of the
English language well this is not true
there is no such thing as not having an
accent even receive pronunciation and
general American themselves our accents
so to summarize we have accents because
humans like to explore and when two
different cultures come together in the
same location the unique ways in which
they both talk get amalgamated into a
brand new accent thanks for the view
subscribe for more thoughty2